the world of business has been rocked by
allegations of misconduct by high
profile senior Executives in recent
years this week the Trav Tesco John
Allen stepped down from one of the top
jobs in British business following
allegations and just weeks after the
director general of the UK's biggest
business organization the CBI was sacked
or were joined Now by baroness modeling
Fox who is president of the British
Chambers of Commerce thank you so much
for being on the program you've had such
an extraordinary CV in career not just
president of the British changes of
Commerce but he was a chair of we
transfer non-executive director of
Chanel Chancellor of the open University
a Serial entrepreneur who set up
lastminute.com
um absolutely great to have you on lots
that I want to talk to you about but if
I may just to start with what's
happening when it comes to the culture
in business at the minute because we
have seen these very high profile
allegations is there a problem with the
behavior of senior people in business in
the UK
that's a that's a big question good
morning Sophie lovely to be here I think
for me it's a couple of things you know
we clearly have now got the ability to
have conversations and raise issues that
perhaps before we brush under the carpet
you know as women as people who felt
vulnerable minorities whatever it might
be I do think how I've got to be careful
to separate very very serious
allegations of rape and sexual
misconduct from what might be determined
as behavior in the office that may be
inappropriate might be old-fashioned
might be much more complex on pics I
just think it's important to separate
those different things but to me it's a
big ship from when I first started in
business and you couldn't even say if
you thought somebody was being a bit
tricky with you or a bit inappropriate
um I can imagine that it must have been
a big shift and you're right that we are
much more able to call out behavior that
is inappropriate now than perhaps
um previously and as you say you've been
in business for many years and you've
probably witnessed or experienced stuff
over uh your time there so feel free to
share and any experiences but I
understand if not do you think things
are improving
uh I I think they are on one level and
uh I can tell you thousands of funny
stories I think everybody uh has
probably
um had a story um or something happened
to them every woman in business you know
everything from when we started
lastminute.com and investor the only
investor that would see me in Brent the
co-founder for and meeting about whether
or not to invest in our business the
first question which he directed at
Brent was what happens if she me gets
pregnant which still shocks me now 25 30
years later but I hear stories all the
time of other people suffering way worse
things than that you know I've had
people call out my clothes how I look
all the time it's endless indeed but I
do think it shifted I do think it's much
more um careful in most business
environments and uh I think that we just
have to recognize that while people like
me might still be very lucky and have
the ability to say things are not quite
right or call out somebody if they're
bad behavior you know we need to focus
on the most vulnerable people in
workplaces if you're a contractor in a
cleaning company working nights from a
minority I don't know where the power
feels as though it's different for you
so I think it's really important we
think about the whole spectrum of people
who work and as always look after and
protect the most vulnerable
yeah I absolutely agree with that
actually and it is easy for women in
high profile positions to talk about
things getting better is it getting
better for the people who don't have the
loudest voices I think is the question
as you say that we do need to keep
asking
there's been all sorts of allegations
around the CBI and I think you're right
to say that it's important to say that
there's a range of allegations here
um do you think that organization is now
finished
you know I don't know nobody wants to
dance on another organization's grave
especially when they've been
reported to bad behavior you know what I
would say is that at this moment in time
it's incredibly important to have the
voice of business
effectively talking into government
chair I'm sorry president of the British
Genesis of Commerce as you said we're a
160 year old organization with members
from local communities represented at a
national level and Global Network as
well and we had our conference this week
on Wednesday and we had the chancellor
there we had the governor of the bank of
England we had care stamas so we are
there we are carrying on doing our job
and so the voice of business is being
represented into government and we feel
really strongly that pre-election with
so much happening in the economy that
the government of all shades and both
sides are listening to what business has
to say and their concerns about the next
18 months two years
what is your number one message to the
government
I think I'm gonna be a cheeky and kind
of safety things I think firstly it's
incredibly important that it's
incredibly important that government
recognizes business feels uncertain
businesses are not looking ahead and
thinking yep the economy feels robust
and yup I feel confident in the
political situation as we've seen
repeatedly in all the data shows whether
it's data about business confidence
whether it's data about actual
investment businesses are waiting
they're kind of feeling a bit uncertain
and holding back and that's bad we need
business to feel confident to feel as
though there is stability to feel as
though they know what the shape of the
next two years is going to be like so
that they can invest that's fundamental
the second thing is around the people's
crisis that we have in this country you
know we we don't have enough people for
the jobs that we want to do we've got
million people uh who have vacancies in
their business it's the single biggest
thing that I hear from talking to
businesses all over the country in my
role British terms of Commerce it's
unbelievably complicated to find some
people in some sectors to then retain
them to retrain them and so on so I
really do think it's a people's crisis
and I hope that the government and the
opposition parties are listening to that
because it's the thing that people come
back to again and again when I'm
traveling around talking to businesses
across the country it's really
interesting to hear what you describe as
a people's crisis at a time when there's
a lot of focus on net migration figures
um out next week which is UNIX says he
wants them to come down you know on the
show a couple weeks ago I spoke to the
former um Bank of England Chief
Economist Andy howdain who said that
actually the government needs to
alleviate some of those pressures
through skilled controlled migrant labor
do you think he's right that actually we
need to embrace more immigration to try
and fill some of those gaps
I 100 do and I think the businesses that
we represent in the chamber Network
would say the same thing we have some of
the Frameworks there already we've got
the Frameworks around short-term
Contracting work for specially skilled
jobs they need to be expanded wrapped up
scaled up and we won't be able to power
up the economy in the way that I think
is possible in this country if we don't
have the people both in our country and
outside our country it's got to be both
it can't be one or the other and if we
shrink and we become closed it's not
going to be good for any of us not for
consumers not for um Business Leaders
it's it's really important that we
address this
um incredible Gap in skills that we have
is it made worse after leaving the
European Union
I think so yes I think it would be very
tricky to argue that this has become an
issue that we've sorted out internally
you know and I don't want to give the
impression that anybody that I talk to
believes we shouldn't be training up and
working hard to make sure that the
people in this country have the skills
we need as well they do need to happen
in parallel we need to make sure we've
got skilled workers from overseas we
also need to make sure that we're
helping our own uh citizens and
employees become as skilled as possible
and also charts for the open University
I think it's time and time again now
people are using that organization to
skill up in their work and move on in
their careers and it's it's vital that
we we have dual track in this in order
to address the enormous challenges that
we face over the next decade it's
interesting you mentioned the
universities there as well because it
does feel that this is another part of
the political debate about whether the
rules should be tightened on
International students and the time that
they can stay in the UK after finishing
a course do you think that's something
the government could look at
okay
so you slightly cut out their service I
hope I'm answering the right question
but uh I hope to talk about universities
and you know I agree I think we also
think um at the University that it's
super important that we keep open and
bringing people to study and keep that
richness of our open University but also
the wider University Network we just
don't want to become a closed country
whatever you feel about the brexit
debate I think that it's been really
important that Britain still feels as
though it's a place that has these
centers of excellence that is
encouraging people from all over the
world to to come in and out of our
country to see the incredible
um university Network that we have and
use it and feel part of it because
that's an incredible soft power that
we'll have over the world when we
um keep those borders open so from every
angle I think we would argue that for
all the institutions that I'm lucky
enough to represent that an open Britain
is a very important player on the world
stage we mustn't become too closed
and politics has already kind of gearing
up for an election next year and it
feels like there's a bit of a tussle
between labor and the conservatives over
who is the party for business who do you
think is coming out on top at the minute
I think it it was definitely I mean I
think the great thing is that both
parties are talking actively about
business and the importance of engaging
with businesses you know 30 of the
people in this country work in
businesses they fuel our economy we're
not going to have any of the ability to
deliver services and the things that we
want to do if we don't have a robust uh
economy and that's driven by business so
it was fantastic that both kirstana and
Jeremy Hunt and Andrew Bailey were at
our conference at the BCC on Wednesday
all of them are talking about the
importance of business everybody's
talking about growth as always you know
we want to see the action behind that we
want to feel as though it's not just
noise but it's also followed through
with action and as I talked about making
that uh business environment feel
certain making sure we've got the skills
we need helping businesses trade
internationally and so forth there's a
bunch of stuff that needs to happen as
well as the rhetoric but the first point
is clearly to make sure that parties are
listening and engaging and that's 100
happening